what case could possibly justify this
magnificent Charles Augustus Magnussen
hey youtubers it's Charlie and it's time
to take one last bow
Sherlock's time is over now so his last
vow just aired and there are so many
things that we need to talk about
including series for which they've
already started working on if you
haven't seen any of my Sherlock videos
before what I'll do is post a
non-spoilery review that's what this
video is
and then tomorrow I'll do a Q&A video
just based on some of the questions that
you guys post in the comments for here
then the day after that I'll be doing a
detailed breakdown of the episode
that'll include all the canned
references and you know cool facts about
the story be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'll also be doing a series 4
predictions video because the last
episode just aired so just to get things
started to hear my top 5 favorite things
about the episode number 5 the jokes the
episode is a really intense drama you
have a villain you have Sherlock and
Watson and the threat that someone is
definitely going to die at the end the
actual pullquote from the trailer for
the episode was sometimes someone has to
die but some of the funniest Sherlock
moments come from some of the most
dangerous situations a normal person
like Watson gets really intense during
all the dramatic moments but somehow
Sherlock manages to slip in a subtle
turn of phrase and it's laugh-out-loud
funny on the other side of that coin
some of the funniest moments in the
episode also come from when other
characters express genuine sentiment
towards Sherlock and he just recoils in
fear speaking of sociopaths number 4
Mycroft he's one of the strangest Holmes
characters and even though he's supposed
to be very emotionally distant Mark
Gatiss still manages to surprise you
with some warmth and genuine emotion
there were a lot of amazing scenes
between Sherlock and Mycroft that
invoked a lot of the classic Holmes boys
comedy the episode does a lot of work to
provide the context for why Mycroft
behaves the way he does especially
towards Sherlock there were even a few
scenes that I actually thought Marcaida
stole from Benedict Cumberbatch that's
how good he was typically people only
see Sherlock when he's on screen so you
can forget sometimes that Mark Gatiss is
largely responsible for writing the
dialogue given to those other characters
so in a way you can actually argue that
Mark Gatiss is the most clever person on
set I'm sure Stephen Moffat would have
something to say about that though
number three the Canon references this
episode has way more Canon than empty
hearse or sign of three even if you
haven't read any of the novels recently
you get a real sense for the importance
of places and events one of the things I
really like about the adapted Sherlock
stories is that it gives you a real
opportunity to rewatch things multiple
times and just find new things each time
nothing in the series is included in the
scripts or in the locations of the sets
of the designs without subtle meaning
everything is connected
Sherlock actually had this really
amazing line during saina 3 where he
said the universe is rarely so lazy and
it's just a metaphor for the idea that
there are no coincidences you always
must be clueing for looks
number 2 the villain Lars Mikkelsen is
definitely a worthy successor to Andrew
Scott's Moriarty Holmes Canon is so vast
that there's always more valence to pull
off the page but it's really the actors
that are responsible for making them
feel like a credible threat to Sherlock
one of the differences that I really
liked between the Magnussen character
and the Moriarty character is the
absence of passion Moriarty was a force
of pure emotion he was like that little
kid on the playground that just like to
smash other kids toys Magnussen is a
self-described businessman just
acquiring and selling assets so if we're
living in the age of information now
he's like the ultimate
stockbroker and my number one favorite
thing the hero's journey what I mean
when I say that is Sherlock's journey
it's the same journey from episode 1 to
now it's like Sherlock starts in exile
or hell any Clauses way back up to
heaven or at least his version of heaven
I saw a lot of you guys commenting on
the big changes he was going through in
each of the episodes and I really just
think it's like Sherlock is slowly
healing himself like he started at the
beginning and he was broken team
Sherlock was broken too and it takes
each episode as well as the entire
series to put things back together so
they can go on having more adventures
the ending of the episode in particular
gives you this sense that there will
always be more Sherlock because we as
the fans need him and because in the
context of the story
England will always need him I guess
that kind of does make Sherlock like a
Time Lord just you know regenerating
himself every time one adventure ends
and a new one begins but now it's your
turn to tell me let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moment
you know was it the plot was it the
surprise twist ending or was it just you
know the funny moments overall I thought
the episode was brilliant as expected it
added a lot more context for the core
relationships between you know Sherlock
and Mycroft and between Watson and Mary
as well as you know between Watson and
Sherlock of course I'm always amazed by
how good the new actors are each season
though
and Abington was awesome and Lars
Mikkelsen was so much fun to watch I
kept having Doctor Who flashbacks based
on some of his mannerisms and abilities
I'll talk more about that during my
break down video but a lot of the credit
goes to red beard for writing such good
characters I mean Mark Gatiss Mark
Gatiss he and Steven Moffat are both
responsible for casting and they said
that the first time that they saw
Nicholson they knew he would be perfect
as the new villain even though the
episode overall is really intense it
left me with this strong sense of
optimism for the future of the core
characters as well as the series in
general to be fair though Steven Moffat
has already been talking about series 5
so you know it's not like we were ever
in any danger of Sherlock going away
just like last time I'll be taking 20 of
you guys questions to answer in my Q&A
video tomorrow so if you want me to
answer something in that video just you
know leave a comment leave a question
I'll mostly be focusing on questions for
this episode but I might also do a
series for Q&A after I post my
predictions video be sure to subscribe
to get that
remember that breakdown video will post
on Tuesday right now click here to get
that Q&A video I'll add the annotation
as soon as I post the video and click
here to get the breakdown thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
you